I know little [ __ ] leave halfway
through around yeah that's my number one
fan not sure it's actually the same guy
hey come on
which basically like
and any
your actual progress so keep you play
through the arena and then hero save at
the lost five and start all over
basically just get all of this money at
the XP and it's the easiest thing ever I
get why they got rid of it because it
was just everyone exploited it I mean it
was kind of it just didn't make sense it
made the game so much easier but I kind
of still liked the option to farm that
way so like you could you know farm for
XP or grind or whatever you want to call
it like grind is probably the record
by like replaying what have you chose to
like the arena
I
you can just do it exactly what you
wanted to and yeah I usually goes here
and there also like West where you again
beeps Silva keys which unlock special
chests and you got these potion things
which i should actually use some reason
that give you like extra will or extra
help experience points I guess depending
on how high your combat multiplier is
when you actually use them and it was
kind of also because you know if you're
in the arena then you can just like
stockpile them based on hero saves norm
world saves and end up with each of them
look at this bridge actually is doing
something not as much as I'm doing a
haha because I am excellent
we
I think she killed someone on that hey
no I damn it royston wash
I can even kill him
oh for goodness
i feel like i'm going to use some of my
ages potions now actually should be in
equipment and then
visions is that it no no it's this one
combat Evolved that's a nice achievement
I don't know what that's full here and
then we go yep
sorry this is not at all exciting but
get me all of the XP is that what I want
I guess both sound good why am I not
already use these so I'm pretty sure
that's the one uses to comment on fire
look I got 20,000 for them
we'll just
yes Matt she's giving me more help why
don't know no use this olya alright this
is silly I'm silly
yeah I do wish there was an option to
use more than one
because yeah I just have to keep going
into the same menu somehow getting
confused every time it works every time
what's up from
I think I just quoted a yeah sixty
percent of time it works every time okay
yes yes that only two more
again and then we'll see how
sexy I am afterwards
oh my god so much more help that is just
what am I even doing
marni take so long as I'm one maybe he's
just not counting in seconds he's just
counting maybe I just give him
the surprise majority of people will
uneducated I'm you know I'm not going to
hate brother can be uneducated if you
most
not only learning that they seem to even
do is the stuff that I give them in
books that I found around the world most
of which are largely inappropriate yeah
this game is also like kind of I mean
this one's RIT um actually but the first
paper game is just like more I guess she
will I want to say more adults
kind of cheeky Oh
I wait
just reasons I just can't I can
understand people liking fables women
and three if they haven't played this
like I feel like it's you know totally
biased in that I was just so
disappointed by the elders it wasn't
necessarily that they were bad but I
don't know I just don't know how anyone
could ever like them more than this game
huh it just doesn't just doesn't make
sense
yo I'm doing well money lying around for
me no I only one worth 2,000 gold 3600
my gonna do with that money I have my
bright will use a suit I don't want
anything else babe I like maybe like a
master katana remember i only have my
food wait you sitting I don't know
whatever it is I feel like I have the
list I like this Rin rounded up bandits
to this great and oh my god that
seriously the arenas in the other games
are just so we'd like they don't even
take any inspiration from actual
gladiators
went ahead it can go on all sorts of
this entirely Thanks crazy guy damn it
take this offshore out let's just
yeah I don't know feelings like this
every day like messy
just feels like every other dumb
an arena it is by definition and arena
congratulations you did the one thing he
was first based
Oscar you got
whoa
schedule
no waiting ok never mind we touch me
what are you doing loud you know who I
am chicken chaser [ __ ]
I mean at least it makes sense that
bandits of dropping money but before
when I was getting a muffled office
because I just how does that even happen
where do they keep that do I want to
know whether today do they have wallets
I don't understand yeah like I'm totally
hitting people all right it's for you
guy no no
we lightning huh
switch
I just fine so damn creepy but
hey trying to get you up let's get your
combat multiplier even though astral
stir you guys to me
she said playing
I don't know what I expected and I think
they can get hurt by that fan thing that
I totally can still alive ah well not
its height in the audience for me money
work you guys money
good I just accidentally used the long
expression
yeah by the way guys I actually swear
fairly in general speech but I try not
to on YouTube but in let's plays I just
kind of can't help it so
trying
he left money man
is it worth taking a bow to my help to
get that sack of money I feel like I
feel like it probably is I mean I would
get hit by a fan for a sack of like
hundreds of dollars yeah I totally do
that without
pretty sure I've like accidentally hit
fans before that one labels
no guaranteed money then I'm not
interested three thousand more go for
that Bennett's done make 6600 know that
is bended agenda now another 4,000 is
available for the next round let's do it
just keep doing it yeah